Olha essa descoberta aqui que é de
enlouquecer. O nosso cérebro consegue
sabotar um tumor cortando o fornecimento
de nutrientes para ele. Pois é, o corpo
tem estratégias que a gente nem
imaginava. Um estudo publicado na PL
Biology mostrou isso usando moscas da
fruta. Olha só, quando falta nutriente
no organismo, um cérebro saudável
aumenta o transporte de aminoácidos para
se proteger, certo? Mas quando tem um
tumor presente, acontece o contrário. O
cérebro reduz esse transporte de
propósito. É como se fechasse portão de
entrada. Veja bem, existe uma proteína
chamada Path, que funciona como esse
porteiro na barreira hematoencefálica.
Em cérebros com tumor, quando falta
nutriente, essa proteína diminui sua
atividade. O resultado, o tumor fica sem
combustível e desacelera o crescimento.
Quando os cientistas forçaram o PEF a
aumentar, mesmo com pouca comida
disponível, o tumor voltou a crescer
rápido. Isso abre uma porta fascinante.
E se conseguirmos manipular esse
mecanismo de forma terapêutica,
controlar o acesso tumor aos nutrientes
pode ser uma estratégia poderosa no
futuro. em decedo para aplicar em
humanos, mas o conceito é
revolucionário.